-It is so great to see you.
-It's so -- you know?
It's just so...
-It is so...
-It's so...
-This Sunday, big premiere.
-Yeah, it's gonna be --
I'm gonna be on HBO this Sunday,
hbomax.com this Sunday.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean -- all right.
-I'm excited.
-All right, let's get there.
I do want to talk to you
and say I know that --
-Yeah.
-You're one of the best
performers, if anyone
has ever seen you live.
But on our show,
one of the greatest performers.
And you haven't
been able to perform live
for almost two years.
-Yeah.
-And then,
you finally got to perform.
-Yeah.
-Wait. What was it like?
-Well, it was a long, cold
winter there for a couple years.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-But going back was really --
It was really exciting.
But I have to say,
I was, like, so nervous.
It's like, you, kind of --
You spend a whole lifetime
building something up.
Like, some crazy person
that's gonna go out
and motorboat people.
You know, make lives change
and whatever, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And then, all of a sudden --
-Sure, yeah.
-And then you're stuck at home.
-But I went back out there,
and I was --
-But you need an audience.
You're great out there.
-You need an audience,
because, to me,
a show is like
a great first date.
It's like, you go there,
you have a couple drinks,
you giggle, some tickle fights,
and maybe you sit on somebody's
lap when it's all over.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, interesting.
Where did you perform
when you went?
-At Joe's Pub.
And it's my favorite venue
in the world.
-Wow!
-It's downtown New York City.
If you guys haven't been,
you have to go.
You never know
who's gonna be there.
You got to get the french fries.
And, you know, you may
see people in the audience like,
I don't know,
Ben Stiller, Gloria Steinem,
or maybe even Questlove.
-Yeah. You never know
who's gonna be there.
-I've seen him
in the audience before,
And I go over, you know,
I like to talk to people
when I'm doing my show
and go out and sort of
mingle with people.
And I'm, like, going over there,
and, you know, Quest is, like,
smiling, having a good time.
He's with his friends.
[ Laughter ]
And then, I walk closer and
closer and I see him sort of
just looking down
and looking around.
-Being like,
"I got to get out of here."
"Somebody Somewhere"
premieres this Sunday on HBO.
-Yeah.
-And you're starring.
This is -- You're -- You're
number one on the call sheet.
-Yeah.
I'm glad you did mention that
I'm number one
on the call sheet because --
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, you are.
-As soon as, like, we got
the green light for the show,
I went on the Internet,
and I just typed in,
"Gold medallion necklace
number one."
And I got myself -- I don't know
if you can see it right here.
But it's --
it's a little necklace
with Pave diamonds
that I got on ebay.com.
-Wow.
[ Laughter ]
-And I'm gonna wear it
every day.
-Number one.
-Every day until they
wheel me up to the crematorium.
It's gonna be right here.
[ Laughter ]
-Number one!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean --
-You got to celebrate
the moments, Jimmy!
-You have to celebrate
the moments.
-I worked a long time.
I waited tables for 25 years,
and now I'm number one on
the call sheet on an HBO show.
-Yeah, that's right!
-So you can do it!
If you can dream it,
you can do it.
LL Cool J said,
"Dreams don't have deadlines,"
and he's right.
-Yeah, that's right.
-Yes.
-What did it feel like?
I mean, because this --
I mean, is it, kind of
loosely based
on your own life or...?
-Yeah, it's like -- You know --
Well, it takes place
in Manhattan, Kansas,
which is The Little Apple.
-Manhattan, Kansas.
[ Laughter ]
-The Little Apple.
So I'm from The Little Apple
and moved to The Big Apple.
But it's, kind of, like --
I'd say the themes
are based on my life.
But it's -- you know,
I go back to my hometown,
and she's sort of,
you know, in her 40s.
Kind of just
drifting through life
and looking for her friends,
but fun.
You know?
-Yeah.
-It's a lot of fun.
-But you do -- you find some --
some great friends and --
-It's about finding
your community and finding your
people, you know?
And finding the things
that are gonna
bring you back to life,
you know?
Because I don't know about
any of you but, like, there's --
Sometimes you can just sort of
skate through like
10 or 20 years, and go like,
"Where did my life go?"
And then, all of a sudden, you
find some people that are like,
"Why don't you
take a chance on yourself?"
I'm like, "Why don't I take
a chance on myself?"
And that's what
this show is about.
-Yeah, I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love it.
And I want to say,
that I've only seen the first
episode, but it is so --
It's so you, buddy.
-Thank you.
-And it's so -- it's so new,
and it's a fresh take.
You haven't seen
any show like this.
And it's very -- it's original.
It's so original.
-Thank you.
-I love it.
And I was -- if I had
your cellphone, I was gonna say,
"You got Janis Joplin
in the trailer?"
I mean, you're just --
"Piece of My Heart"
is in the trailer.
-I just -- you know.
-Yeah, no big deal.
-HBO makes the call.
They make things happen.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It's so good, and it's funny.
And it's just --
It's -- It's heartwarming.
It's everything.
It's everything you want.
-Thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip
from the show.
Here's Bridget Everett
in "Somebody Somewhere."
Take a look.
-Sorry, I --
I lost my sister six months ago,
so I'm a little...
-I know.
I'm so sorry about Holly.
She was a few years
ahead of us, right?
-Oh, God.
I'm sorry. I didn't --
I didn't realize that we went
to high school together.
-We were in show choir together.
-No, I --
I knew I recognized you.
-No, you didn't.
-I didn't.
-It's all good.
A lot of people
don't remember me.
Hey, if you want to take off
for the rest of the day,
I'll tell Irma
you got diarrhea or something.
-[ Sniffles ]
Yeah?
And it made me cry?
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah.
Bridget Everett, everybody!
"Somebody Somewhere"
premieres January 16th,
this Sunday, at 10:30 p.m.,
on HBO!